Підігрівати воду в чайнику на газовій плиті вже цього
опалювального сезону може бути значно дорожче.
Ціна на газ для населення має бути ринковою.
На цьому наполягає МВФ. Урядовою постановою затверджено
відповідну формулу встановлення ціни в Україні
залежно від середньої ціни на імпортний газ за певний період.
Ціна зросла і відповідно мають подорожчати
і платіжки для населення. З урахуванням націнок
постачальників, транспортних витрат та податків українці
вже з жовтня мали б платити за блакитне паливо
на 20 відсотків більше.
Втім, уряд поки "заморозив" це підвищення
і намагається переконати МВФ змінити формулу
встановлення ціни. Газ і пенсійна реформа –
одні з головних тем переговорів для отримання
багатомільярдного траншу від Міжнародного валютного фонду.
Київ переконує, що підвищення ціни на газ
матиме негативний ефект. Люди просто
не зможуть платити. За даними уряду, заборгованість населення
за спожитий газ вже складає
26 мільярдів гривень і може
збільшитись ще на половину від цієї суми.
Друга причина – субсидії. Їх вже отримує
60 відсотків домогосподарств, а після зростання
ціни на газ може бути аж 90.
На думку експертів, уряд нині між двох вогнів.
З одного боку, є ризик, що підвищення ціни на газ,
яке також зачепить тарифи на гарячу воду і тепло,
пожвавить протестні настрої у суспільстві.
А з іншого – під загрозою співпраця з МВФ і відповідно
фінансова підтримка бюджету. Фонд наполягає на ринковому,
а не політичному регулюванні ціни на газ.
Київ намагатиметься змінити формулу розрахунку,
щоб для визначення тарифів
враховувався лише період, коли ціна на газ на європейських хабах
найнижча.
За даними експертів, на компроміс може піти й МВФ.
Зокрема, погодитися, щоб тарифи не змінювалися в обмін на жорстке зменшення субсидій.
На нинішній опалювальний сезон ціну на газ для населення,
швидше за все, "заморозять" або вона зміниться несуттєво.
Не зважаючи на можливі проблеми з МВФ,
це рішення знову стане політичним, щоб уникнути
соціальних потрясінь.